you know i so
when my brother um passed
i started journaling a lot right you
know but then i stopped
okay i started i just ripped out all the
pages and threw it away because i
couldn't really look at it
yeah you know and then uh once i moved
to la in 2018
that's when i started really doing it
that's when i really started [ __ ]
just journaling because i was like
because yeah i was like i was like i
don't know this city i don't even think
about it
everyone you know claims to know how la
is
yeah you know but a lot of times i'm
like you know you've never lived there
you know i've never lived there you
never lived there you i mean you're
going off
as a visitor mm-hmm you know what i mean
um
so when i when i moved there
you know that's when i really got back
into it because
you know you got a lot of you i mean how
many people are trying to be comedians
i can't imagine especially in la right
you know i mean people are trying to be
actors
you know people are trying to be
something yeah out there
so [ __ ] much people want to make it
people want to [ __ ] make it
you know and i was i was one of those
you know
i i just was like man [ __ ] it why don't
i just go out
you know and work and just
like why don't i just go okay i i just
simplified it
and got rid of all the [ __ ] pressures
of trying to make it
because that's it's an insane that's a
big [ __ ]
i mean especially in that world because
if you don't make it because it's not
it's not a guarantee
you're setting yourself up for failure
oh yeah you're going to set yourself up
for
you're going to go crazy you know i
didn't want to [ __ ] do that
it's like a rat race out there oh my god
everyone trying to everyone trying to
become famous
everyone's trying to become famous yeah
and people don't know how to be their
their most authentic self yeah and i was
like well
everyone's doing that i'm one of those
dudes that like it
there's this [ __ ] cesspool of [ __ ]
going on yeah yeah
i go ah let me
you know i look around like i'm like man
i don't want to go over there
let me do it like this right you know
like i said it was one of those things
like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] act because people go there
acting like they know right because if
they act like they know then
they think that people were like oh yeah
this guy knows what's up this girl knows
what they're trying to act like somebody
they're really not even yet exactly
you know i'm like i'm not doing that i
don't know [ __ ] all right
yeah i don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] it my
biggest thing with those people
is just like what if you just run into
somebody who
actually does know who has an experience
or who can like open doors for you
oh yeah you show up and you acting like
you you're trying to preach to them
they're never gonna [ __ ] talk to you
you're a joker yeah
i go yeah i go i don't [ __ ] yeah
whatever so how did you get your
initially get your foot in the door to
like the comedy scene i mean you're
pretty like
well entrenched with like all the big
comics in la right now
how did you enter that world or how did
you get you like your big break if you
will
yeah um i mean
so yeah i'm trying to think of like the
best way to explain it
i just started doing i just started
doing me
okay and i was going out and doing like
open mics
yeah just going out doing it then people
thought i was funny they were asking me
to be on shows
and it just kept building from there
because
shows you mean just like open mic shows
so like not the open mic show so like
open mics to like actual booked shows oh
wow yeah like yeah
and the thing was like i always like i
learned this from like dave girl
yeah foo fighters guys yeah he was like
if you're loud enough people will
[ __ ] hear it
and he goes he uh like when he drummed
from nirvana
yeah he was just like if you're loud
enough people [ __ ] hear it
you know and i i thought about that i
was like yeah
i feel loud enough people will hear it
so if you if you're good enough
people will [ __ ] hear it right
they're going to come yeah they're going
to come
they're going to come i promise you and
you know a lot of times you see people
like man like
i can't believe i'm not getting this i'm
not getting this i'm not getting you
know
it's like we keep [ __ ] saying that
they focus on the numbers they're like
yeah and it's like dude [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
don't use that as a [ __ ] excuse
yeah i hate that [ __ ] so [ __ ] what
it is so people want to make an excuse
as to why they're not getting something
just [ __ ] do you just be just exist
exist loudly i can't start my podcast
yet because i don't have enough
subscribers yet
yeah like a thousand subscribers yeah i
you know oh this place doesn't you know
book
you know book me because of this or you
know
weird [ __ ] like that it's a story yeah
and it's like man if you
uh you know just realize you suck
[Laughter]
that's not what you think yes
[Music]
no it's not the place yeah
i think about this [ __ ] all the time i
think about a lot of [ __ ] you know
just [ __ ] very you know introspective
is that the word i'm looking for
perspective yeah and yeah i just do a
lot of
so much of looking within that you know
and it's so funny because i'm on uh
that's good i feel like the smartest
people do that
i i i appreciate that damn that's a
compliment
well i mean they do i mean the smartest
people i've met they are like that and
they they spend a lot of time writing
and journaling that's why i'm always
curious about like asking about
like process like how people build the
discipline to like or the habit of
always writing and journaling and like
if you have a thought just like writing
it down and working it out yeah and like
working out so you can talk about it or
speak it clearly
or speak it to an audience yeah you know
you know people think i'm crazy because
i don't
watch the news or anything like that
people think you're crazy because of
that yes
i'm sure a lot of people probably think
that yeah like it's they're like how do
you
how do you not know this i don't [ __ ]
watch i don't
i don't watch things i don't like right
right i don't pay attention to [ __ ] i
don't like
that's the [ __ ] that's another like
yeah like why
i'm not i don't give a [ __ ] right right
like like it's like weird like uh up to
date on all the
all the facts yeah i'm like okay what
yeah cause a lot of times when i really
think about it i go what can i do with
this information
it's out of your control yeah that's out
of my control i don't give a [ __ ]
argue with your aunt about it yeah yeah
exactly you know
someone was trying to talk to people uh
about dr dre's divorce
i was like oh god how so
what the [ __ ] that gotta do with me i
don't even know the guy i don't know
them you ain't getting any money yeah
yeah that's like it [ __ ] drives me
crazy
right now it's like a hot topic yeah
they're like how do you not know this
how do you not how dare you yeah how
dare you not know this
because it means nothing to me it means
nothing to me
it's so funny man some people have one
on like conversations they just want to
have conversations about that [ __ ]
dude most conversations like the dumbest
[ __ ] man i'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here like
like i don't [ __ ] i'm trying to think
of some things i don't like
i'm just [ __ ] oh man um
i mean everybody this is that's
everything on tv yeah
yeah yeah i don't like nickelback i
don't pay attention to them
sorry if you guys are nickelback i'm not
looking back
okay you know sorry to the nickelback
fans out there i mean yeah
i mean i don't like so i don't i don't
[ __ ] pay attention
right but you're not out there like hey
did you hear their new album it's yeah
did you see what
nickelback did right here
you know it's just like like that's
that's you know
like that [ __ ] up your brain so much
when people do that
you just painted them yeah you're
wasting time why are you paying
attention to [ __ ] you don't like
mm-hmm like how do you know that i don't
know
what
he's like i [ __ ] can't stand michael
rap i can't stand him
do you know that guy no i don't know i'm
not personally i know he lives in l.a
yeah dude he is funny dude oh my
god i love that guy he's crazy he's so
crazy god damn i was [ __ ] i respect
him because he [ __ ]
yeah he does what he does he doesn't
hold back that's him
yeah uh but yeah he was like i don't
like what he says i go
you follow him yeah right why do you why
do you [ __ ] yeah i was like why do you
follow him
oh cause that's the internet
yeah god damn he's funniest oh the
internet is crazy i mean i had to get
rid of they follow most people
just to hate on people
foreign